I still had a leftover stolen from
Christmas so I thought I brought it what
it's almost it's still somewhat still
okay to eat what is it what did you
bring it's a Stalin I mean because this
is a picnic so I brought oh it is a
picnic you are dressed like a picnic
blanket yes and we're having Stalin and
then I got some Deutsche beer paulana
we're having a whole German experience
here yeah do you want do you want a
German beer it's paulana I love to have
palano you don't have to talk in an
accident yes that's rude that's my girl
that was really rude yeah but I don't
mind I don't mind okay but Heidi Heidi
you came out she's she's very careful
because I'm a picnic blanket that's why
okay but how do you open these you're so
prepared today who brings who brings a
picnic to a podcast swim and beer
I don't drink I'm not drinking right now
does anyone have an opener
um yeah I'm sure my son my son he's not
on his keychain yeah my son is always
ready for a picnic Alex come in here
thank you thank you thank you okay so
you came you dressed like this picnic
and you walked out Heidi the first thing
you said is I have a hedgehog I have I
have a hedgehog underwear on why she
didn't just say no because she didn't
just say it I saw it how did you see her
Underpants she showed me she flashed her
she showed me and we need a knife please
what cheese
we need a nice please this is a stone
okay so this is kind of like a Christmas
bread it's sweet it has like a Stein
it's called stolen so this is sweet it's
kind of a sweet bread and it has like
raisins in it it has marzipan and then
can I say something you started by
saying it's a Christmas bread yeah you
realize this is March that's why I'm
saying I think it's still nobody wants
to touch it is there an expiration where
has your stolen been in the last two
months where do you stick your stolen to
keep it fresh there's a knife it says
two nine twenty two two nine twenty two
last February last month February 9th
but no but in Germany you're gonna cut
your knee you're stolen you cut the tip
off your stolen
[Laughter]
that was months ago yeah but it's
Germany and we do it the other way
around so what do you mean it's still
good to like till next yeah
no 20 no till September 9th of September
till the second of September yes just
don't read too much into it it's still
simple don't read too much into it don't
eat too much into no because we're doing
it the other way around how what do you
say
see he tried it he loves it stolen you
love to taste Heidi stolen
who doesn't want to taste Heidi stolen
me I think that I think that button
flies are the chopstick of a zipper he's
not even near a mic again he's not near
a mic it doesn't matter he's Googling
things he's making you really I have to
eat this
I don't I don't have to either no I will
but thank you it was a good idea so when
I called you Heidi and I said let's do a
podcast you went and got your hedgehog
Underpants and stolen
you're not making a it's a really good
face no it is really good it is really
good I like it people have been
requesting we our listeners have been
saying more eating more eating oh really
yeah they've been saying this so this is
for the listeners oh man you you ask you
shall receive
um
this is right from Germany because it
tastes like it might be from Sweden no
this is a German man but maybe they have
a Swedish one too what are you talking
about Lou
if I got arrested in Sweden
it would be fine because they couldn't
coerce me because I don't speak the
language okay
so anyway
Cheers Cheers Cheers I'm not drinking
I'm drinking uh I'm I'm like uh I see by
the way this is not an end or anything
just so you know it's just German bien
because I'm German I thought I'd bring
you like some German stuff I don't know
if anyone would think that this was an
ad I think that you you showing up with
the fact that you showed up and you
brought us plenty of German stuff yeah
um
we have expired bread I love it I was
gonna think it's an ad no no but it's
not because in Germany we do the month
and the day the other way around we do
that in Canada too so this is good till
September so the second of September
yeah what are you doing he's getting
more he's getting more and if it was
February
February of this year
this year it's just only just March I
just
you don't that's the other thing I
noticed about Heidi you don't diet you
don't really you you're in incredible
shape yet you don't seem to um it's it's
genetics right
I think it is
I think it is too you have a lot of it
is and a lot of it is what you eat oh my
God oh my God you must eat a lot of
stone and drink I'm feeling psychic this
rarely rarely happens to me but I'm
feeling psychic I'm feeling psychic the
people that are watching and listening
give me oh
the letter b o b i see the letter b o
some somebody in the in the audience
with the letter b b o b o
boo is there a boob I think there's a
boo boo boo out there somewhere in the
audience listening or watching there's
somebody by the name of boo boo boo it
was psychic it's just looking at Alex my
brother's face whenever Lou starts to
say it's like a call to Prime but that
was I had to do it but you didn't notice
uh Heidi was looking at me and mouthing
the words what is happening oh
you're not the only one that's saying
that everybody is thinking what's
happening
[Music]